right now an investigation is underway
into that deadly crash of a fighter jet
happened just outside of nellis air
force base alex the crash really shook a
neighborhood they're used to seeing jets
take off and land there safely
all the time hector mejia live at the
scene right now which is still very
active this morning hector good morning
to you sir
good morning investigators still combing
through the debris and looking at what's
left of the charred plane it actually
went down right behind us right behind
those homes you see in this neighborhood
this morning the national transportation
safety board looking into this crash
that's because the jet belonged to a
civilian contractor which operates out
of nellis air force base
and this morning we know the pilot was
the only person on board
and died in the crash viewer video
showed the fiery aftermath and black
smoke billowing into the sky
just before 2 30 yesterday afternoon
thankfully no one on the ground was hurt
but neighbors described
the scary normal scene
could tell there was something wrong
with it so i looked at it and it was
coming down
very fast and it was pretty low i'm
86 years old and i never seen anything
like that in my life only on tv
the ntsb says the plane that went down
was a dassault aviation mirage
f1 nellis air force base tells us it was
a contracted aircraft that was owned
operated and piloted by draken us
a company that provides adversary air
support to nellis
dragon calling this a tragic loss of one
of their pilots and the name of the
pilot
has not been released and it could be a
while before we learned the cause of the
crash meanwhile as you can see right
behind us the scene's still very active
we'll have another live update still
ahead in less than half an hour
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now